fated to welcome Johnny Smith from
ascension I'm a real major partner of
the chess bug in our scholastic effort
absolutely we're the Fergusson the
system Maurice well Johnny Smith who is
a senior director of public relations at
Ascension and ascension has just been a
fantastic partner with the Chess Club
doing great work in the Ferguson
fluorescent district Johnny welcome to
the show
thank you tell us a little bit about the
work that you guys do with the young
people there in Florissant yeah so a few
years ago Nick were going our chief
marketing officer had a vision and his
vision was to expand chess into school
districts across the st. Louis area and
you know with the enthusiasm from dr.
Davis who was the superintendent of
Ferguson flourescent schools we found
the right partner to really start and
embark our new program it's been a
fantastic partnership that we've had
throughout the last several years around
400 kids have been helped in 13
elementary schools across the Ferguson
flourescent School District so we're
very very pleased to be able to deliver
the service and this program to many
students in the area and we see these
wonderful images on screen right now the
kids being very enthusiastic and you had
a fundraiser on March 7th which you do
every single year how did the fundraiser
go this year it was fantastic Maurice
over 125 thousand dollars raised
corporate donors we had blitz games we
had raffles it was just fantastic so
many people came together because people
came together with one mission in mind
and next to extend the game of chess to
kids all throughout the area oh that we
all know the many benefits that chest
delivers to communities and we know it's
a true sport the discipline some the
mental gymnastics as we call it it's
just been a fantastic partnership and we
think truly all the st. Louis partners
were there unwavering support for the
kids with in Ferguson flourescent how
many kids have been affected by this
program so yeah so many kids have really
been participating over 500 kids have
participated in the program see it
initially started as an after-school
program but because of dr. Davis and his
leadership throughout the
in Florissant school district it's now
actually in their curriculum so kids are
actually getting it almost every day
with the certified trainers from the
Chess Club so we're so pleased about the
partnership so here's what I want to
know do you play chess I do not but I'm
going to tell you this I'm going to tell
you this I have two boys
six and four and I have started to
introduce them to it because I didn't
have access to a program like this when
I was growing up but because of the
enthusiasm that this is generated here
in st. Louis I can say that safely say
that my children are actively involved
in it as well when the kids are getting
involved you know it's got to be a good
thing right
that means you believe in it yes we
appreciate the great efforts ascension
continues to make over the years and of
course the contributions tell us the
website that people can go to they want
to make contributions themselves yeah
well first just go to ascension dot oh
that's our website or just go to the st.
Louis chess club all right Johnny Smith
Senior Director doing work over there
thank you very much for everything that
you do Thank You Maurice